33.9 J 76
87 si ça s'ouvre, ce sera
cool Concentrez-vous, je pense que c'est non ouais, je
traverse
l'
altitude, ok, ok, essayons de faire le
tir ouais peut-être euh ouais euh,
pouvons-nous descendre vers l'ouest alors
je vais juste regarder ailleurs  notre euh comme le
parallèle de Western Hollywood là-bas ouais parallèle
à Santa
Monica
ok
demande
ok donc à propos de cette ligne ouais c'est bien
et à quelle vitesse euh tu peux tu peux aller
relativement vite nous sommes si haut je ne
pense pas que ça va avoir de l'importance
ok quand tu  'est terminé avec cette course à laquelle
tu vas revenir, c'est que
[Musique] c'est
vrai
que le
contact 414 Victor approche
12.63 essaie de ne pas quitter cette
ville3
ne perds pas
le ne le perds pas non d'accord oh je vois que
tu es  en disant très
bien, nous allons, nous nous en
éloignons, même si c'est le
seul
problème
6 Sud-ouest 181
r
12 700 11 000
avec le littoral
ouais 181 trafic
2 agréable et grave si c'était clair, ce
serait vraiment quelque chose ouais
1801 contact approche 28.75
28.75
sou
papa4
vior tu me préviens quand tu démarres
ton on en fera deux pour
Victor
quelle est notre altitude
maintenant vraiment
bonne 2994 sur 2000 pour
4,000
main8
294 tourne à droite
294 est-ce que c'est B tu vas
bien comme scuba
divic là  pendant un
moment ouais, nous allons juste lentement en direction
ouest ici jusqu'à 3 000
pieds 7,
bonne, quelle est notre
vitesse de l'air faible
peuvent-ils augmenter beaucoup ce contraste,
que peuvent-ils augmenter le contraste
et publier beaucoup de choses, vous savez, faire le
SW noir ou est-ce  la fumée
attends
peut-être de maintenir cette altitude
ouais désolé je me demandais juste s'ils
pouvaient s'ils pouvaient augmenter beaucoup le contraste
à Poston avec cette sagama je pense que
oui je pense que euh,
fais-le noir, ils peuvent ouais
9 théâtre des impôts
District j'ai du noir
gamma noir gamma y plus 25 et tu
dis que les grilles le seront, c'est comme
seulement euh, ça ne sera clair que
deux semaines dans un an ouais et ce
n'est pas comme deux semaines d'affilée, c'est comme si
tu en avais quelques jours  jours ouais, je veux
dire, tu auras quelques jours et
ensuite tu pourrais avoir un mois, puis
en fait, quand les vents soufflent,
c'est le meilleur mais il n'y a pas d'incendies
ouais donc euh octobre et mars sont souvent
très bons ouais en Sp de ce que nous voyons
en ce moment, en octobre, il peut tu fais juste
un panoramique pour voir la grille de ton
côté euh à euh à gauche vers le P à
gauche attends où es-tu à droite
ouais déjà allumé donc tu veux
je ne peux pas  sans heurter le dérapage, ok,
tourne la main maintenant, ok, merci
[Musique]
toi
Ville nordb
1 500
euh toio P centre-ville oui, je le suis, je viens de
commencer à faire un panoramique avec
toi, je pense que c'est un peu le genre de
ça, c'est vrai, je veux dire, nous pouvons y aller un
peu plus  si tu veux mais des
pistes désertes dans ces
montagnes je m'arrête à cet
arrêt ouais et deux4 Victor plane au-dessus du
côté des cèdres à
1,7
rue